Bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin sur
RT France alors à en croire ce sondage
les jeunes préférais Emmanuel Macron et
la droite radicale plutôt que la gauche
est-ce que ce sondage vous étonne
Valentin au délice
non moi ça m'étonne pas alors vous
parlez de droite radicale moi je me sens
pas vraiment radical je suis sur des
républicains aujourd'hui j'ai rejoint
la droite
parce que
Éric Zemmour il mobilise la jeunesse on
le voit sur les réseaux sociaux on voit
sur le terrain on le voit par exemple
génération Z et maintenant aujourd'hui
l'un des plus gros mouvements de
jeunesse
politique
moi je suis pas surprise
les pas véritablement surprenant j'ai
pas la première chose que je ne t'ai pas
donné là c'est que c'est encore moi qui
a 5 ans qui souhaitent aller voter qui
disent souhaitait aller voter puisque le
taux de participation envisager à
diminuer et on retrouve globalement une
fracture avec
les et qui vont aller voter sur un vote
institutionnel utile c'est-à-dire le
vote du président de la République
sortant et des jeunes plutôt en
situation difficile avec qui vend les
hôtels à l'extrême droite pour après
traditionnellement le les candidats de
droite ou du mal sur cette électorat
note que ça dit pour cent et un niveau
supérieur est-ce qui était François
Fillon est-ce qu'il veut dire donc on a
une marge de progression sur sur 7 axes
la priorité de ces jeunes la Santé vient
en premier suivi de l'éducation la
sécurité et la lutte contre le
terrorisme on va le voir un sur sur
cette infographie l'écologie viens
seulement en 4e position c'est étonnant
et la lutte contre le covit un loin
derrière là aussi ça vous surprend ou
pas cette cette idée des priorités
Valentin des Lilas la santé l'éducation
et la sécurité
non ça me
choque pas ça me surprend pas en fait il
y a un vrai problème de santé notamment
et campagne avec la désertification
ça c'est qui existait déjà sous Hollande
et qui est gravé avec Mâcon
donc il y a un besoin de santé même à
Orléans par exemple on a des problèmes
de médecin pour trouver un médecin
généraliste spécialiste
en priorité des jeunes
ça touche aussi déjà sa serviette aprèm
ça touche également les jeunes c'est pas
seulement
pas seulement les retraités ou les
ménages où ça touche aussi la jeunesse
qui a du mal à trouver des médecins
simplement et pas seulement pas
seulement en campagne il y a un souci
envoie quels sont tes vêtements devant
tous les autres on est sur des thèmes
qui tiennent à un ou deux. Donc on est
vraiment sur ce qui a classiquement les
marge d'erreur de des sondages la santé
c'est un véritable sujet alors
effectivement la question de la
désertification médicale en zone rurale
mais aussi en
politique de la ville où on
en est
prioritaire je crois que c'est quelque
chose d'assez logique et assez cohérent
les autres thèmes vous indiquez quand
vous regardez bien entre le 2e et 4e ou
5e mission dans deux ou trois points non
on est vraiment sur des points qui ont
une valeur à peu près égale
sauf que
c'est pas non plus énorme Emmanuel
Macron président
de
la
République en marche
et
François Patriat
un ensemble de mesures prises pour les
jeunes se sont pressés dans les
mutuelles pour les étudiants le Pass
Culture tout ce qui a été fait pour les
jeunes pendant le covit vide ou un jeune
une solution en 2017 elle s'était déjà
les jeunes avec Macron qui avait apporté
leur soutien 4 ou 5 mois avant et c'est
en signal pour appeler à la candidature
de Macron
de François Patriat voilà la fiche de
campagne justement menée par les jeunes
avec Macron président des jeunes ils
vont consignes pour une cinquième saison
1 commentaire Valentin playlist surtout
qu'on vient de voir
moi je confirme ce qu'on peut voir sur
les réseaux sociaux et c'est-à-dire que
cette affiche les jeunes avec Macron qui
colle qui qui l'école ils ont beaucoup
de cheveux blancs
c'est clairement il y a pas de jeunes
avec Macron
existait en 2017 mais ils ont été déçu
pourquoi ils ont été déçu c'est simple
parce que c'est pas juste
après je vous l'accorde ce ne sont que
des sondages
[Musique]
intentions de vote
à la présidentielle
[Musique]
c'est
pour ça dégoûtant j'ai 29 ans
écouter qu'il affirme il est en campagne
mais c'est un secret de polichinelle
aujourd'hui
et
qui
est
Emmanuel Macron
on est un quinquennat avec un président
de la République qui parle à
1215 20 % des Français quand on tient
compte de l'abstention avec qui sont les
personnes et tant mieux pour elle qu'il
ne souffre pas de la crise qui ne
souffre pas de la paupérisation qui ne
souffre pas de la désertification des
campagnes il ne souffre pas de problème
d'insécurité majeur et en fait c'est une
partie de la France mais on est sur un
point de la République qui me le
rassemble pas il n'a pas su rassembler
qui n'a pas su donner confiance et donc
aujourd'hui sujet c'est d'essayer de
garder un socle
électoral entre 2025 et 12 à 15 % de la
population qui vote pour lui pour les
faire mettre d'être deuxième tour en
espérant être contre les femmes droite
pour pouvoir faire un deuxième mandat
qui effectivement
on est
qu'
est-ce que c'était une erreur
c'est complètement déplacé je suis pour
le coup extrêmement ancien monde je
considère qu'il y a des choses qui
doivent pas être mélangé avec la parole
public la puissance publique c'est pas
de la petit peu lisation c'est pas du
show-biz et que un président et Hollande
c'était un président ne devrais pas dire
ça bah là c'est un président devrais pas
faire ça
écouter
Macron président des Jeunes écouter il a
pas été tendre avec le président
le seul truc qui l'ai fait pour la
jeunesse c'est d'être lui-même jeune
c'est un président jeune mais il n'a
rien fait pour eux à la fin du
quinquennat il y a des jeunes qui sont
aller à la soupe populaire car il
n'avait pas à manger pour moi c'est un
bilan que je qualifierais de minable
alors il y a tout à fait raison moi j'ai
vu ça à Orléans université d'Orléans
j'en ai vu des comme ça pour justement
des étudiants qui aller chercher en fait
la base où est plus il pouvait plus rien
faire à cause de la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron et sa gestion
[Musique]
alors pour les étudiants et ça c'est
un autre perdu pour des millions de
jeunes
à cause de la session de Manuel Macron
ah oui oui je pense qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui si ils savent ce qu'ils vont
ils vont voter massivement contre il va
y avoir un vote contre Macron voir quels
que soient les personnes ont test au
second tour ils sont toujours très
proche de la victoire par contre je
pense qu'il est sous-estimer dans les
sondages
en tout cas
il a le service national universel
incroyable qui coûte beaucoup d'argent
pour quel résultat final service
universel pour vous
mettre en place
bon je pense pas que ce soit une
mauvaise chose après c'est quelque chose
qui reste assez marginale sur le
président de la République de
la France
[Musique]
avec tous les 13 ans ou la France
symboliquement préside l'Union
européenne pas pour faire que la France
influe sur les murs open mais pour faire
que l'image de l'Union européenne l'aide
à essayer d'être réélu je trouve ça
assez dommage pour le pays dommage pour
l'Europe est assez triste politiquement
quand on s'intéresse à l'engagement
public
qu'est-ce qu'il y aura le poids de la
dette apporter pour pour la jeunesse
est-ce qu'elle en a conscience selon
vous c'est
quoi qu'il en coûte rien n'est jamais
gratuit dans la vie
actuellement on est on a été à lisser
ouvert demain tu as permis d'amortir
certaines choses mais la réalité c'est
que la facture elle tombe toujours un
jour et ça c'est pas quelque chose sur
le quai de la République fait campagne
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose auquel
serons confrontés celles et ceux qui
auront à gérer le pays dans les mois qui
viennent et avec et avec en plus
ils
n'ont pas été porter des retraites
tu es par une partie de la jeunesse le
mouvement génération Z qui ont dit que
5000 membres une jeunesse qui veut
défendre une certaine idée de la France
et se battre pour la sauvegarde de la
civilisation des jeunes souvent issus de
grandes écoles écouter
ces jeunes issus du sérail premier des
carrières brillante ce n'est pas rien de
s'engager dans ce camp politique ils
savent ce que ça peut leur côté il ne
l'avait pas fait avant pour Marine Le
Pen par exemple avec Zemmour c'est un
risque ils sont prêts à courir
simplement parce que ils ont réalisé
très rapidement que Marine Le Pen de la
fonction de l'emporter aujourd'hui Éric
Zemmour est capable de gagner ça ça
change tout et en plus il a une culture
il a une capacité à s'exprimer
c'est pas comme à chaque fois dans une
permanente et
qui dure depuis très longtemps
bah
je sais pas si on peut dire enfin parti
aujourd'hui c'était quelque chose avant
qu'on pouvait reconnaître
aujourd'hui c'est pas très clair
pardon mais on a plus le temps
malheureusement Valentin merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé à ce débat Merci à
vous également Jean-Philippe du moins